but first joining us now the author of
The New York Times number one bestseller
understanding Trump former Speaker of
the House Fox News contributor Newt
Gingrich although a Newton has an online
course called defending America mr.
speaker good to see you again good to
see you I must say I thought that the
historic speech that President Trump
made in our nation's today was really
about defending America but it was also
about defending the right of every
country to be a sovereign nation it's a
truly a remarkable speech it's the
fourth great speech of his presidency
and I think it sets the stage for a real
debate worldwide about globalism versus
sovereign nations who work together but
they work together as independent
countries not as some kind of a
globalist internationalism you know
Democrats ripping this is bombastic and
dangerous and I'm looking at the words
of the speech and he says okay he
reiterated his commitment to America
first our government's first duty to his
people to our citizens to serve their
needs ensure their safety preserve their
rights to defend their values and as
president always put America first and
he takes on North Korea that's firing
missiles over Japan almost on a weekly
basis and he takes on radical Islam and
radical Islamic mullahs and Iran and say
they can't get nukes why am I having a
hard time understanding the criticism
here well because I think your worldview
and mine and I'm with you on this is so
radically different from the appeasement
oriented left you have to remember that
from the standpoint of the left this is
a dangerous speech at every level it's a
speech which says that America matters
and remember when he says he's going to
put America first he went on to say and
he expects other leaders to put their
countries first he's not saying America
first over everybody else but he's
saying if you have a national leader you
know if the leader of Britain or the
leader of Germany or the leader of China
if they're not putting their own country
first they're not doing their duty to
their people now out of that you got to
negotiate you've got to come together
but I thought it was a very compelling
speech Mad Dog Madison Emeril mattes
said that the US may have a secret
weapon neutralized North Korean when he
was pressed why you laughing when he was
pressed further he said well he talked
about I don't want to get into it when
he was talking about kinetic options
what in your opinion is that a clue as
to what might be the option they're
talking about first of all he has been
going around very methodically talking
to our missile command inspecting our
ICBMs talking to the Strategic Command
laying out what we could do I don't know
any secrets and I deliberately have
avoided clearance of you as I do so much
television but but let me tell you from
general source open sources Boeing has
developed a hypersonic missile that
literally knocks out all of the
communications all of the computers as
it passes over a headquarters for
example we have a variety of cyber
weapons that we normally don't talk
about and we never use because we don't
want other people to know we have them I
think that if there's a terrific scene
in Gladiator where Russell Crowe says
when you see the signal unleash hell I
have a hunch that matters in the
beginning of every orchestrating the
kapap okay
I think Madison's very methodically
organizing and the ability to if he has
to he doesn't want to he's not a guy who
believes in taking giant risk but if he
has to I think he is prepared to take
enormous steps to disarm North Korea and
to do so in ways that most people would
no idea we're capable of I've been
saying there's no good options that to
me would be a really good option well
imagine you woke up as kim jeong-hoon
and your telephone didn't work and by
the way your radio didn't work and you
weren't in connected kind of contact
with your generals and your generals
weren't in contact with each other and
you all of a sudden that your rockets
didn't work launch anything because
because everything had suddenly been
stopped now whether or not we could do a
hundred percent I'm not sure I have a
hunch we could do a lot and I think that
we have had very smart people work this
problem for very many years and it's one
of the reasons I was proud that we had a
huge bipartisan majority passed the
Armed Services Building
this week because it's a signal that now
we're coming together as Americans not
Democrats or Republicans and we're
saying the world question we're gonna do
what we have to do to defend ourselves
big time
let me go back to March 4th of this year
when the president pointed out and
tweeted out that he was being wiretapped
well we now found out that in fact the
president was right and we did as I said
in my opening monologue we talked about
this on March 8th and Sarah Carter and
John Solomon broke the story FISA
warrants other warrants and we know what
happened but there's the bigger broader
issue here of the unprecedented amount
of surveillance of a political
opposition candidate on masking of
people in the case of general Flynn
leaking intelligence and then you have
people like Samantha power the the UN
rep unmasking up to 300 people most of
them Trump people then Rhodes Susan Rice
and you have to ask yourself what is
going on here and how dangerous is this
to the Fourth Amendment from your
perspective well I think if you would
take all the different ways in which the
Obama Justice Department was abusing the
system abusing it on the one hand to
defend Hillary Clinton abusing it on the
other hand going after Republicans and
people are for Trump this is I think
this is a radically bigger scandal than
anything about Russia
here you have an administration which
deliberately was going after political
figures which on the other hand was
deliberately defending its own political
figures this may be the most egregious
abuse of the criminal justice process in
American history I mean it's truly
extraordinary and nobody yet has put it
all together and I'm hoping that the
Congress is now going to realize that
they have and you said it well in your
opening monologue I mean it was general
clapper not informed that there was a
FISA warrant ordered general clapper lie
about the Pfizer warrant there are a
whole series of these things that come
out of these reports and we take the
totality there they're quite astonishing
and it goes back to the point I make in
my course on defending America which is
the country you
I know is under siege by a deep state
which really wants to create a very
different America and is willing to
break the law and abuse the law in order
to achieve that all right mr. speaker I
totally agree
thanks for being with us